the New York times is attacking
us for chip Chilla that's our most
popular kids show my little boy
sometimes he goes to bed and I says da
can I bring chip Chilla and he's got a
little stuffed animal you know he loves
chip
Chilla the fantasy of the fun TV dad in
the children series Bluey and its
conservative knockoff chip Chilla that's
how they describe they say we're
knocking off because we have a basic
children's show that's normal that was
like every children's show until 20
years ago uh they say it's a knockoff
boundlessly attentive fathers step into
a suage parental
anxieties so the New York times is
attacking not just chip Chilla but also
this show Bluey which I've never seen
but I guess it's I don't know similar
type of show it's just a show that would
would have been normal kids content like
all kids
content 20 30 40 years ago so they hate
it this is the New York Times on chip
chill they say I don't know how he keeps
house this is the daddy the doggy Daddy
I don't know how he keeps house works as
an archaeologist and serves as a
full-time prop artist to his daughters
but he does it all while only feigning
complaint he is not only a good father
he is a fantasy one crafted to appeal to
adults as much as to Children feel very
bad for this critic here for the New
York Times Amanda Hess because the
reason I mention the article is not not
just cuz they're going after chip Chilla
or not because of Bluey which I don't
know anything
about this
woman can't even
imagine a good father being
real the New York Times the
libs they can't even imagine the
possibility of a guy being a good
father part of this not I'm not getting
into any psycho Babel with the author or
even the New York Times editors but part
of this I find is that all liberalism
ultimately comes down to screw you
Dad 100% of the time 100% of the time
it's not even a personal Insight I
discovered that I heard it from a buddy
of mine Greg years ago he used saltier
language and I laughed and I thought wow
you're so right all every lib I
know to some
degree hates his dad everyone I don't
know it's weird but once you see it you
can't unsee
it and even if not you're Earthly father
I think it's 100% of the time even with
their Earthly fathers certainly with
their Heavenly fathers they've got some
gripe against God the Father you know
this the cosmos the the create the way
that the cosmos was created how
everything works here they just but also
it just very basically they just hate
their dads they all have daddy issues
and it's very sad to me that in the year
of Our Lord 2023 the libs it's not even
that they say I I had a bad father and I
should have had a good father or it's
not even just that they're saying well
fatherhood needs to be tweaked a little
bit or there's some issues with the way
fathers are expected to be it's they
can't even
fathom a a
meticulous
attentive responsible fun loving father
they can't they say it's just a total
fantasy they go on as I watch the show
over my three-year-old son's shoulder I
wonder what Bandit says about the latent
desires of the parents queuing up the
show more than 100 episodes are
streaming on Disney plus with more
arriving in January after all when I
turn on Bluey I'm being very unbanded I
am not engaged in focused play that
follows my children's imagination where
it leads I'm cleaning my son is staring
at a
screen so the guilt that this person is
feeling
for allowing their children to watch TV
a
lot is leading them to attack the show
say it's unrealistic that parents would
actually take care of their kids parents
do it I'm I'm not knocking screen time
too we I think everybody does a little
bit of screen time every now and again
but believe it or not there was a time
when
parents did spend much more time with
their kids it was a lot easier when
women didn't have to work now women do
have to work it's not it's not that
women get to work now women have to work
in most economic
circumstances liberalism presents that
as a choice an active empowerment it's
not a choice for most people it's a
requirement of our current political
economy that was very intentionally
structured that way and so women they
have this illusion of choice but they
don't really have a choice they're
forced to go out and work for some
random guy who owns the widget Factory
and they have to labor in the widget
Factory so that they can make enough
money to bring home so their husband can
pay some other woman to raise their kids
and when they don't pay some other woman
to raise their kidss and they don't send
them to daycare or state funded or
private they stick them in front of a TV
and they have the the TV raise their
kids and they feel bad about that
naturally I and it's not even just a
personal failing it's a it's a social
failing it's a political failing that we
now have a political economy that almost
forces you to do that but that tension
that that feeling of guilt is what is
impelling very clearly she's explaining
it here it's impelling some of her anger
some of her
or dissatisfaction with the show right
now go to pre-born docomo this Christmas
season is rapidly approaching while you
are writing out your Christmas list
remember that we are now in the season
of giving and if you are not sure what
to give I will tell you give the gift of
life through our partnership with
pre-born pre-born is an organization
that has rescued over 270,000 babies
from abortion by offering free
ultrasounds to abortion minded women
once these women meet their babies for
the first time they hear that heartbeat
the babies Chan at life is doubled it's
very simple woman hears the ultrasound
twice as likely not to abort her child
for just 28 bucks you can save a life by
sponsoring a mother's ultrasound
pre-born also supports mothers by
providing them with diapers car seats
counseling and more every day pre-born
network of clinics rescues 200 babies as
they compete head-to-head with the
abortion Giants now through a match your
tax deductible gift is doubled your
donation offers double the blessings and
that is double the chance at life for a
baby now is the time to put your yearend
write offs to work have your donation
matched today by dialing pound 250
saying keyword baby that is pound 250
keyword baby or donate securely at
pre-born docomo that is preborn docomo
wle right now go to jus.com there's a
lot to be stressed about during this
Christmas season stress and lack of
sleep can easily cause those pesky under
eye bags the good news is you never have
to worry about that again when you have
genus cell skincare from now until
Christmas genus cell's most popular
package has a special discount just for
our listeners at Jus cell.com
nkw treat yourself and your loved ones
to the absolute best skincare in the
world those troubling forehead wrinkles
Fine Lines skin redness even a sagging
jawline will disappear right before your
eyes with genus cell's most popular
collection genus cell promises immediate
effects you will see results in less
than 12 hours guaranteed or your money
back jell made Christmas come early this
year they sent down a ton of products
for the whole office everyone is raving
about the under eyee cream this works
wonders plus included in every most
popular package is your free hyaluronic
acid serum for skin hydration and
restoration you deserve to look and feel
good this Christmas season you know I
love this company I love the founder
Coptic Christian from Egypt left for the
American dream uses absolutely the best
ingredients out there an amazing
discount on your first order because
you're going to be a customer for a very
long time go to Jus cell.com
kwes get this great Christmas discount
every pre- order instantly upgraded to
express free shipping today janus.com
she goes on it's typical in children's
stories for Parental figures to be
obscured or even absent especially the
mothers Disney movies I grew up on
Little Mermaid Lion King featured
authoritarian fathers who following the
untimely deaths of their wives ruled
their children from a distance while
Outsourcing their child care to a crab
or a
bird I don't know that that's exactly
how I would describe the Lion King it
seems a little a little off but anyway
my son's favorite show is not Bluey but
Mickey Mouse Clubhouse in which Mickey's
parentage is irrelevant he's a god-like
figure who answers to no one that is a
fantasy for children total parental
Absol lescence well no it's a fantasy
for your your
children that's the difference here this
New York Times writer I don't know where
this person
lives I guess New York I should assume
but who knows big
newspaper she is ex she has inculcated
certain values in her children we all do
inevitably that's that's what what
education is that's what parenting is
and so what the liberals do is they
inculcate liberal values and the liberal
value is is one of not the U Unity of
the generations not of respecting one's
elders and caring for one's young and
and recognizing an an unbroken thread
between the generations that gives us a
respect and a reverence and a care for
the the traditions and the institutions
that we've inherited and a and a desire
a charitable desire to pass those on to
Future Generations it it gives one the
the desire to break free of all of that
to view the past as as baggage as as a
burden as oppression to view the future
as something that does not deserve our
care or our attention it's not our
responsibility to break free of all the
bonds the bonds of politics which is
viewed as oppression the bonds of family
also viewed as oppression the bonds of
morality also it's all viewed as
oppression even the bonds of biology now
in this case where where people are told
to break free of their very bodies so
that if their
body uh shows their identity to be one
thing they will break free of that
they'll say damn my body who cares I'm
going to be something totally different
that that's a liberal view the The View
that the little child that the
individual should be God that's the
liberal view that's not good not the
kind of thing you want to inculcate in
your
kid but the New York Times writer the
New York Times editors can't imagine
that in the conservative parts of the
country in the conservative house
households that's not the child's
fantasy because children's fantasies are
they don't just pop out of the air okay
they they develop as the children are
educated children are sponges and desire
is mimetic so the way that we human
beings come to desire something is not
not just uh written into the code of our
DNA necessarily and it's not just
because an object is intrinsically
desirable it's mimetic we observe the
desires of those around us especially
those closest to us and those we respect
like our parents and we emulate those
very
desires clearest example of this is a
Rolex watch no one really desires a
Rolex watch because it's a they know all
that much about horology no one really
desires a Rolex W some people like the
way it looks some people like the
history of it some people like but the
biggest driver for why people desire
Rolex watches is because other people
desire
them the the reason that you covet your
neighbor's wife is not because she's the
hottest chick around it's because she's
your neighbor's wife that's that in fact
that's why coveting that's why mimetic
desire is is is included multiple times
in the Ten Commandments because that's
so intrinsic to human nature and human
desire and so this woman seems
completely unaware oblivious that she
has cultivated certain Desires in her
kid and that's the desire to be a god
that's the desire to be totally free of
all bonds freee of parents that's not
the desire that conservatives cultivate
in their kids what conservatives
cultivate in their kids is I think a
much healthier desire which is to love
your family love your community respect
your parents be happy when your dad
stays home and plays around with you she
goes on I wonder if one of the upsides
of Bluey from a parents perspective is
that it works to absolve our guilt over
screen time if we feel bad for ignoring
or subduing our children there we go
there's a little bit of self-awareness
creeping in yeah yeah I wonder if blue
at least offers a simulation of
boundless parental attention right
you're yes you're you're becoming
self-aware New York Times lady and
you're recognizing that that's a good
thing to have your parents pay a lot of
attention to you and it would be nice if
if parents did that out of choice or
even were able to do that and our
political economy were not such that you
had to go to the widget Factory all day
yeah you're right why do you have that
guilt why do you have that guilt because
it's by enacting liberalism you are
denying things that are that we know
naturally to be good
the moms in BL this is the final
paragraph I'll mention it's a long
article it's worth reading the moms in
blue and Chip Chilla Chile and chinny
don't get the classic Disney movie
treatment they're allowed to live they
get to join in the fun too though Chile
is more levelheaded than her husband and
chinny is Stern both mothers are granted
supporting roles in their children's
imaginative worlds though they are
somewhat sidelined by their plots often
because of their work outside and within
the home in chip Chilla this is the this
is the money line in chip Chilla chinny
is the one stuck holding the laundry
basket and that is why the New York
Times ladies of the world the Liberals
of the
world won't be able to resolve the
tension they're feeling
because they're just like their little
kids demanding to be Gods they're just
like their little kids demanding to be
totally free of all natural constraint
and all natural
inclinations because they resent that
the woman might do the
laundry and the man might go to work
outside of the home every Every Body
Works they they resent that they resent
that men and women are
different but someone's going to have to
go work outside the home so if you deny
that men and women are
different then you're both going to go
to work outside the home and if you both
go to work outside the home then you're
just not going to get to spend as much
time with your
kids and that's a sad
fact these are the people who who want
this the the New York Times these are
the people who are driving this there
are so many people I
know I mean I think it probably most
people I know the woman Works outside
the home often not by choice those are
the people that I feel the sorest for
here those are the true victims of all
of this because we now have and we've
had it for almost a hundred years now a
political
economy that that forces this situation
and that that makes it into an
unimaginable fantasy that you would get
to spend a lot of time with your parents
especially with your mother could you
imagine you imagine back in the old day
those old awful days when your mother
was stuck holding the laundry basket and
everyone was really happy and that story
is actually so attractive that two two
shows are about that and they happen to
be two of the most popular children's
shows around man what a great clip that
was huh that was good now hey oh ring
that Bell subscribe to the Michael NS
YouTube channel we'll see you next time